[Music]
welcome everyone to another episode of
kiwi talks my guest today was a
developer at valve for over 14 years and
worked on titles such as half-life 2 and
portal 2. i'd like to welcome joshua
wire how are you doing
good thanks for having me
yeah likewise thank you so much for
taking time out
i'm sure this is development time so i
appreciate it
that's right i'm always it's always fun
to go back and reminisce on what i've
done in the past especially portal 2
because it was such a
massive part of my gaming career yeah
well you worked on that for quite a long
time so does it get to a point where
things just blur like can you remember
everything vividly
or just stuff that's just blurred
half-life 2 is more blurry to me because
that was so long ago yeah um and i was
really young like at the time i think i
i turned 21 when i started working on
that so that was like you know most of
my adult you know career life was a
valve but um
it's weird because i i i would say no i
don't remember and then i was like i'll
just watch a play through quick just to
refresh my memory and it was like oh
yeah that bug and i remember that place
and oh yeah that thing and it just came
flooding back really quickly so yeah i
think i was just so
intimately involved because i was the
project lead it was like just every
little piece i knew about um although it
it's funny because they're i run into
maps where i'm like i don't remember
this map being the shipping map i
remember playing it a lot in the testing
phases and then at some point the artist
came in and like made it look amazing
and i'm kind of like it's like going
back to somewhere after 20 years and
you're like i think i grew up here but i
don't quite remember it looking like
this like it just has this strange like
almost nostalgic uh feel to it in that
way so yeah it was kind of weird to go
back and and relive it
yeah so how did you end up becoming the
project lead on portal 2 was that
something that you advocated for or did
you just get approached to do it
yeah it was kind of a weird thing so
when we were working so i worked on
episode two as well yeah and so making
episode two was hard and making tf2 was
hard and making portal was hard but we
thought hey why don't we make it even
harder and we'll ship them all at the
same time so that's when we ship the
orange box and on top of that we're like
hey let's also ship on the xbox which we
hadn't really done much console work so
we didn't really know what we were in
for so it was just this massive awful
like deadline trying to get that to work
and after that everyone was super tired
and it was kind of weird because the
whole company had kind of finished at
the same time when you usually were like
staggered um so that you know things are
coming out at a different pace and so
after that um
some of the the guys who were trying to
think about what to do with the company
especially tom leonard who was working
there at the time said
hey why don't we do something more
interesting why don't we break up into a
bunch of little teams and we're going to
do what we're going to call the um
design experiments and we're just going
to basically take some time
make little teams of like four to five
people one person is going to lead it
just to give them a chance to have some
you know
you know ability to show that they could
lead or how they work with people
and it it didn't it could be gameplay it
could be technology it could be art it
didn't really matter it was just going
to be kind of a somewhat structured
thing that we could all do so that we
could sit down and like um
just kind of jam a bit
and then the hope was that we would take
whatever we came up with and that would
kind of roll into the next thing but it
was kind of this nice creative reset and
i think what he was thinking too and i
didn't realize at the time is that it
was kind of a good way for him to say
let's give like a bunch of people a
chance to
like lead projects and be more in a
management role with really low risk
right because if they completely flop on
this little experiment it doesn't matter
it's you know two three months it's not
a big deal
and so we had all kind of gone off and
um i think just naturally at the time i
was becoming
a little bit more in a leadership role
in ep 2 and so they were like hey you
take some people and you captain this
one
and so we went off and we what made what
was called f-stop um and we've never
really talked about that so i can't go
into the details but f-stop was um it
was a puzzle mechanic and it was a lot
it was kind of in the vein of portal
that's kind of how we had pitched it is
like hey here's this cool little thing
and gave a presentation on it and
everybody was super excited about it and
they were like oh man this is great
somehow this has to be portal 2. um so
they're like okay you're going to be the
lead of it and you're going to co-lead
with garrett ricky who is a super smart
guy who was on portals of the original
portal team from digipen
so he and i kind of looked at each other
like
okay because um that team had been
working on their own pitch for what they
thought portal 2 would be and we were
working on something separate and now
they were kind of trying to cram the two
worlds together and go okay guys come up
with something that works with this and
f-stop was not necessarily something
that fit easily into that world
and we were coming at it from this
standpoint of like well this is the
puzzle mechanic this is what the
company's telling us they want so let's
figure out how to cram that in there
and so yeah from that point on it was
just like six months of beating our head
against the wall trying to get that to
work until we were able to kind of we
had a few events happen that really
helped fix that for us and got what
portal 2 ultimately was kind of kind of
rolling but that's how i fell into it it
was kind of
did this little thing and it worked out
and then they put me on a bigger thing
and you know they just kept piling
responsibilities on me until i fell over
well it teaches you what is it uh sink
or swim sort of that's mentality yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so i've seen the the pictures that you
posted i think on twitter of
the initial stickmen
whiteboard drawings so was it yeah was
the entire game mapped out that way like
room by room
pretty much yeah um
it was
one really cool thing about portal like
you know i was looking back on hl2 and
hl2 was hard because there's a lot of
art assets it was really organic things
you know flowed in different ways and it
was just really convoluted in a bunch of
senses so that was hard to put out but
portal kind of in its conceit was about
testing and it was about these little
test chambers and we sort of inherited
that structure so it was great from a
design standpoint because we could we
could just say this is the room elevator
here elevator there glad to see
something when you come in she says
something when you go out maybe there's
some interactions in between
and it just let us focus on like okay
what are we trying to teach you in this
one test chamber so it was really
awesome way to focus our design because
we weren't trying to mix a bunch of
things together it was like all right
this one's all about the redirection
laser
boxes
we need to teach you this how we're
going to do it okay let's lay it out and
then it was really fast to go make that
because you know the the test chambers
were pretty boxy and so it was really
really quick to just kind of bang that
together and go okay done
and there were a couple neat little
tricks we did too where
usually it's kind of annoying in game
development where it's like okay if
we're going to put an elevator on one
side an elevator on the other side you
have to physically kind of move them
into place and you know make sure
everything was adjusted
but we got portals so good and the
transition's so seamless that what
people don't know is that when you're
coming and going out of those elevators
there are actually portals at those
doors so you walk through that door it's
actually a portal it just doesn't look
like one and so we could do these cool
things where we would just basically say
this elevator which is randomly over
here in space connects to this room and
then that connects to this other thing
that's over somewhere else in space and
you could just logically like you know
eye dropper and say go to there go to
there go there and we could also then um
do that with multiple different test
chambers so it was super cool because it
just freed us up from a bunch of boring
stuff right the elevator could just be
this really nice felt thing could live
anywhere and no one ever knew that we
had you know been using portals behind
the scenes as like developers not just
you know in the gameplay sense so that
was always kind of this fun thing that i
don't think anyone ever really noticed
because um david kercher who did a ton
of the work on the portals and making
them seamless had got it so good that
just never knew
you're just stepping into a hallway but
really you're like you know teleporting
over a huge vast space
that's so interesting so how do you get
the gameplay ramping right in terms of
puzzles right because you don't want it
to be too hard where people are just
like i have no idea how to complete this
yeah uh that took a lot of work but i
the big thing that we did for portal was
play testing was really the heartbeat of
it
we kind of settled on the structure
where it was like okay every friday
we're going to bring somebody in they're
going to play our work we're going to
talk about it monday and then we're
going to do it again on friday
and so
that just ended up being this really
good heartbeat for the project because
it scoped our work really clearly and it
made that just really simple to know
what the next best thing to do was
and part of that was us sitting down
saying okay we know we have um
x number of mechanics so what we did at
first was originally when we started
portal it was kind of more like a hub
structure um just so that we could test
things and so you'd be in this little
hub and that's kind of what co-op ended
up
adopting so you go off down these little
corridors and we'd come up with like
five or six mechanics i think all of
them shipped except for one um
and we just laid track with that it was
just like okay um
you're gonna do all the catapults you're
gonna do all the
tractor beams you're gonna do all the um
the laser redirection and all that stuff
and then within each track you would
have like okay well here's the intro we
just have to show you the most basic
thing and then maybe we'll show you
another thing and then we'd have what we
would call like a quiz where we would
kind of take what you had learned and
try to make you apply it a little bit
different than what you had
and then we'd always have something that
was called the we called the graduation
where that was like
it's there's some lateral thinking
involved in this it's not just
do by wrote what you've done before it's
like hey we're going to ask you to
extend your knowledge and you're
thinking a little bit now that we've
trained you well enough
and so once we kind of had that arc we
would sit that down and say like okay we
think that's the right arc and then we
would just play test that and see where
people got stuck and
it was a hard thing because
you know i think porter was kind of cool
in that we didn't have difficulty levels
and
kind of everybody felt really smart even
though everybody was doing the same
thing like we didn't give you a lot of
chances to do different things but i
think that that step of that lateral
thinking made you feel like oh yeah i
came up with this this is i'm a genius
like no one's thought of this when
really it's like you know everybody
thought of it that's okay yeah and so as
we were playtesting we had to be really
careful because um sometimes we'd bump
into a problem and we'd have to be like
okay is this person an outlier what is
it that they didn't see and and it we
had a really big process around like how
to ask questions in a non-leading way so
we could try to go like
because we we would think like i don't
think they saw the button but i can't
ask them if they saw the button because
then they're gonna you know so it was
like trying to figure that out and it
would always just kind of take the
smallest steps back we could until we
started to hit enough traction we're
like okay now people are getting it
let's not touch it anymore um because we
didn't want to you know obviously fall
back too far or have one person who's an
outlier and then go oh we gotta like
change everything and then you know the
other nine people who played would have
been fine so
that was just i mean we played those
test chambers hundreds of times so it
was just like refinement refinement
refinement
and that's that's kind of how it all
worked out but then it was kind of weird
as a pacing on top of that because
you had the puzzle pacing but then you
also the story pacing yes um and when i
was watching through i had forgotten
something that happened because in the
beginning of the game
the test chambers are kind of ruined
yeah and you're watching gladys rebuild
them and then you hit this point where
everything's fixed and we realized as we
were doing that what that when you got
to the part where everything was fixed
it looked really boring like everything
was it had been like back to sterile and
nice so we're like well this doesn't
work and that's why right when she's
like hey i fixed everything it's great
that's when wheatley takes you off
behind the scenes and we did that over
and over again where we'd have to wait
to like okay i think this is just where
it's about to get boring and we'd throw
you a curveball and kind of push you
into the next sequence so that it never
got to the point where you felt like man
i'm tired of these white walls i'm tired
of you know the you know
just what i've been seeing for so long
we just had to keep finding ways to make
that fresh and so that was this extra
layer of going
okay we got seven puzzles to get through
but we also have to like throw in enough
stuff to keep you mentally busy because
a lot of times people be like why am i
just solving puzzles so it's like okay
yeah we have to wheatley has to come in
and you know give you a little bit of
motivation to move forward or gladys has
to do something that prompts you
so it was this really tight coupling
between
the designers and the storytellers to
figure out how to make those mesh really
well so that one didn't feel abrupt and
you didn't you didn't feel like you were
soaking in this really boring
environment for a long time we really
just wanted to kind of keep you going
especially because it was weird
and that
you would like have this chase sequence
and then you'd be thrown into a puzzle
and you'd spend 15 minutes in a puzzle
beating your head against the wall and
it's like chase sequence and then back
into a thing so that was weird too it
was like you would just have these
really abrupt starts and stops and so
again it was just we just played the
hell out of it and just watched and
watched and tweaked and talked and yeah
it was just this labor of love of like
constant iteration
so what was the thing that came first
was it story that was the main focus and
then gameplay or was it the reverse
because the thing is as well
because usually with games if you tweak
something to the story when you're part
way through to the development you have
to end up messing with the gameplay and
changing stuff around sometimes which i
would think in portal 2 or portal for
that matter it wouldn't be as much of an
issue
and you guys didn't really have cut
scenes either
so yeah
but
so we so eric wolpan and jay pinkerton
were the main writers and and chet
falasek worked on co-op but that was
kind of its own like that was his own
thread those guys just ran and did their
thing
jay and eric
just like i mean they first of all they
killed themselves on that project they
worked so hard on that but they were
really intent on waiting as long as they
could before doing the actual work and
it was part of that where they were just
like look i don't want to write a bunch
of stuff and then you guys come in and
change it like you know you wave your
wand of like well this takes me five
minutes to do and you just waved away
like you said you know five months of
our work so they just kind of waited and
waited and waited and in that time they
were sort of building up they're putting
in the bank i think things they knew
that would work so they were putting in
jokes that they knew were going to be
kind of able to put anywhere
but in terms of like the overarching
story
that kept getting refined and tweaked
and changed and you know uh
jostled around up until the last minute
and it's funny because even when i
watched back in the play-through there
were things that i kind of forgot were
in there because they were so incredibly
late
that a lot of the cave johnson stuff and
especially the caroline stuff was super
late in the game so some of it i'm kind
of hearing going oh yeah i forgot we
recorded that because it literally was
in the last month and i was so like
crazy doing other stuff i didn't have
eyes on on that
um but even stuff like um
the moon shot at the end
um where you you know you shoot the yeah
for everybody yeah it's been out long
enough i think yeah
yeah yeah
but uh that was this really late thing
and that was a funny process too because
i was in most of the meetings and uh
that meeting i didn't go into i was just
like i got stuff to do you guys got this
like go crazy and they came back and
everyone was like hey we had this idea
and i was like
okay i hope we can pull that off but i i
think that was the nice thing about
working at val i was like if you guys
are super passionate you're gonna make
it work like i'm kind of scared of it
but it sounds great go crazy um and then
at that point that was pretty late in
the process too and so the writers had
to go
okay like why can you shoot a portal on
the moon and that's and then they had to
kind of go back and retroactively put in
a bunch of stuff with like cave getting
sick from moon dust and all that stuff
like that all came on as a result of the
moon shot not as a
you know a deliberate thing so they were
really good at going back and kind of
filling in where they needed to to make
that work and that was a big part of
that refinement too of going okay this
seems like it's sticking let's go back
and add as many little uh indicators to
this as we can and so i think they did a
great job of like just hustling at the
end to like cram all that stuff in
so was it quite a linear pro if you
think of in terms of the rooms right was
it a linear process in terms of
designing the room so you'd start off
easy and then get hot get harder as you
progress or was it something that was
just completely out of order and then
you just mesh and change the rooms
accordingly it was a little of both um
because when we started it was just
going okay
we have a catapult so the catapults came
online and they were called faith plates
but we always called them catapults
forever so that's another thing that
came on light they like add all the
aperture science nomenclature and like
it's not deep in my mind so i'll call
them catapults but
you know that that came from okay we
want to do this conservation of momentum
where you can fly through the air but we
don't want to just have to do drops all
the time and catapults would give us
more ability to have that high flying
craziness without
having so many design constraints around
what the room was like
so that one was kind of more linear it's
like okay let's just
let's sit down and we we know we that's
where all the whiteboard drawings would
come we'd sit in a room with all the
team and go okay let's come up with
everything we can think of for catapults
and we would just
you know bang out like five little
little um uh puzzles for that and then
we'd say okay let's build these and then
friday we'll play test with somebody and
we'll put them in a rough order and then
from that we would kind of say okay well
that one's harder than this one and
obviously some of them would have to
come before others because we couldn't
put the hardest one and the thing that
asked you to do the most things at the
at the beginning it would have to be at
the end so some things were easy other
things were sort of more you know it
could be a b or c that you learned next
because they're not necessarily
dependent on one another and then it was
just sort of you know up to us to figure
it out
other things
like especially the um projected walls
that are the the bridges that you could
walk on the light bridges yep those were
things that
we
originally thought like okay it's
traversal it's this we'll just make
these things
but because we were iterating in a bunch
and because the designers were playing
with those mechanics a bunch somebody
was like hey check it out if you do it
this way you can make a wall and we're
like oh what could we do with the wall
and then you'd go and make 10 more
things and then oh if you do this way
it's like a ramp and this way it can do
and you know and then suddenly some of
the mechanics would just have these
weird like things that we didn't think
of at first and that was
i mean it's not problematic in the sense
that it's good to have them but it's
problematic because we had this track
and we're like okay well now we have to
take these things and kind of fill them
in there and sometimes that meant okay
let's cut this puzzle it's not as
exciting as this other puzzle
and so yeah was this constant shuffling
of like you know i i had spreadsheets of
what the track was and it was like okay
this is shuffling into here and this is
here and this is the hardness and i
think over time it became less
less academic and a little more gut you
know gut feel as we had done it enough
but yeah it was it was definitely like
just a constant revision process because
i think if we had sat down
and made a design talk like it would
have been outdated in five minutes just
because of the pace we were working at
and and again because
we were just playing it so much that
there was always something cool and
interesting coming up and the team was
always talking and just kind of you know
there's this great creative energy
around just coming up with the next
thing and i think too because the test
chambers are so simple to make and also
to kind of conceive
you could have people who are just
not map designers sit down and like
whiteboard out a puzzle and go hey i've
got this idea what do you think whereas
normally in a game
that would kind of work but it'd be a
lot harder because you might be like
well i don't know where to put this or
that's really difficult but important
was like oh yeah you could totally do
with the catapult in the box
and all these pieces that you have um so
i felt like there was this really great
um creative on-ramp for the team that is
harder in other games where people like
anybody could just come up and say hey i
thought of this thing and then everybody
would riff on that and then that would
become a puzzle and that was really
gratifying
and i think that was a big key and why
we had so many interesting weird little
things because it could just these ideas
could flow in from so many brains all
the time yeah so was there any mechanics
that you just had to drop just due to
time constraints or hardware limitations
at the time
uh there were two that come to mind so
one was um
the paints if you remember the paints
there was like the blue paint for for
bouncing the repulsion gels yep there
was another one that i believe was
purple at the time uh and that one was
you could walk up on walls
and oh cool we come up with all kinds of
cool ideas for that but the problem was
that um it just made people sick so fast
and
we
because i
we we always
we for whatever reason throughout my
whole career um motion sickness was like
this key thing that we were always
bumping into because you know in hl2 you
had a bunch of vehicles you would drive
and people would drive and get sick
right away so this was really early in
the game and we didn't know why that was
really happening
so we were coming up with kind of all
our random ideas for why this was but
anyway the the
the
adherence gel i think it was called i
don't remember uh you would step on the
wall and it would like rotate your
camera and now the world has changed and
uh
we had one person mark laidlaw who was
the writer for hl2 and mark was really
susceptible to motion sickness they were
like okay i think it's okay we've done a
lot of work to smooth it out let's get
mark to do it and he literally took the
first step on the wall and changed his
head and he's like i gotta go lay down
we were like okay it's like i don't
think we're going to be able to get this
to work so it wasn't the worst thing to
cut um but i feel like that probably
would have filtered out a lot of people
who would have been like i just i can't
do this and and that would have been a
shame so we that one didn't make it and
early in the project we had something
that was sort of a bullet-time-ish uh
mechanic where you could slow down time
because the original portal had a lot
more kind of reflex-based gameplay and
that was
good in some respects but it tended to
filter out a lot of people who would
have otherwise enjoyed the game so we
tried to step back on that and say we
don't want to do a lot of reflex heavy
stuff
but we thought hey if we added something
like bullet time then you could jump
through there and do crazy things go
into bullet time shoot some portals
around and be a ninja
and that was true there was a lot of
neat things you could do with it but it
just felt it it didn't work as smoothly
because you needed an extra button and
it just sort of felt
a little strange compared to the rest of
the game so just from an elegant
standpoint we were like this this
doesn't really fit with everything else
let's just you know we'll weed that out
and not worry about it so maybe somebody
command that back in
so from a scripting standpoint an
engineering standpoint how difficult was
it to implement things like the the
jowls and the beams
yeah um
a lot of the stuff wasn't too bad like i
i
early in the project like i i made the
the faith plates and the the tractor
beams like i was still able to sit on my
keyboard for a while and do those things
and those are pretty quick um just
because we had a robust physics system
so those things just sort of fell out
automatically
the gel was really hard um we
so kind of in in the the i guess the
tradition of portal we had hired some
students out of digipen who had worked
on a game that was all it was called tag
and it was you know all about spraying
paint around and doing all the things
that you did and we're like okay this
seems like it would fit how are we going
to do this
but we had this big graphical problem
which was like how are we going to make
this now look super hokey because if you
go to a bunch of sprites it's not going
to look right
and we had had a grad student who's i'm
sorry i knew his name i forget because i
didn't work with him directly
but he had been working on some
technology around
creating like kind of blobby shapes out
of particles you don't see and kind of
building meshes in real time so it was
this awesome tech and we were like oh
give us that please that is exactly what
we need to do what we need to do here um
so he came on and he worked on that um
and it came on pretty rapidly where we
just had this really cool stuff and then
neat things fell out where like oh you
can put the paint in the tractor beam
and look at all coalesces and you can
move it around and do all this neat
stuff and it's like physical in this
different way um so that came online
pretty well but then
we had given ourselves the extra
challenge of wanting to be on the
playstation at the time
and so the playstation just had this
really different architecture than what
we were used to and so we had teams of
people working just to make the blobs
work on the ps3 and to utilize you know
the way that architecture worked
differently
and actually the weirdest the hardest
thing by the end ended up being the ps3
i think it was ps3 um in that we had
this really awesome sound design like
all these little robotic arms moving
around and like lots of um scripted
sequences and the the sound guys had
done it so that as the robot moved they
would keyframe certain sounds to certain
things so they would go
instead of having like one big sound for
that they would break it into the
components and man the ps3 was not happy
with that and so that was actually the
most stressful thing shipping it was we
were right at the end and we were like
oh my god like we have painted ourselves
into this corner now where we have these
sounds and we're not sure how to make
that work on the ps3 and luckily you
know there were some really smart guys
who were able to kind of
parachute in and fix that at the zero
hour so luckily we made that work and
david fisa who did a lot of the sound
was able to like kind of frantically
undo a bunch of his meticulous beautiful
work to sort of like you know coalesce
it back into something that would ship
um but a lot of the other stuff i think
was fairly straightforward actually the
hardest thing
probably technically was smoothing out
portal transitions
because in the first game it was pretty
good but there'd be a lot of times where
you'd walk through a portal and
something would snap or you'd see that
there was a disconnect
or you you'd turn through it funny and
it would kind of be sickening and david
kircher who had made the portals on the
original game made it his life mission
in this one to make them flawless
and man that guy a super smart guy he
spent so much time like just agonizing
over every little thing and he had come
up with all these weird names like there
was a there's a time with portals where
you kind of come up and like the
portal's here and you want to come up on
a ledge so usually what would happen is
you'd like pop around in a funny way and
it would just really be disconcerting
and so he came up with what he called
the david bowie move where you would
kind of do this and you'd nicely come
over and he was kind of referencing in
labyrinth where the the goblin king
comes around so i i don't know if people
know about that one but um that was
actually the the hardest technical thing
because
he just wanted it to be perfect and i
think he he got really really close in
the end and you just don't think about
portals and you don't get sick moving
through portals but there's other weird
things about portals too like
um
when you jump into a portal
the worst thing in the world we saw in
play test is people would put a portal
on the ground they'd put it where they
wanted to come out of they were super
hyped they'd jump off and they'd like
smack into this little pixel right next
to the portal and they'd be like and
they'd have to climb back out and do it
again so we actually added a bunch of
tech that would kind of funnel you and
help you so as you drop if you weren't
going to hit the portal we'd kind of
push you very slightly into the portal
just so you'd have a better experience
and there was a bunch of other work
around like if you were holding a box
and went through a portal a lot of times
the box wouldn't come with you and then
you're like
so we had to do a lot of work to like
make the box come with you and so
that kind of stuff was all behind the
scenes and hopefully nobody ever knew
that it was there it just made your
gameplay experience passively better and
you didn't know about that so those
oftentimes were the hardest things to
try to to hide but also to to make you
still feel powerful when you went
through the portal even if we bumped you
a little bit this episode of kiwitalks
is proudly brought to you by manscape
the world's leaders and below the waste
grooming and today i'm here to talk to
you about the performance package 4.0
which is the ultimate peak hygiene plan
so let's get into it first of all we
have the lawnmower 4.0 which is an
all-new skin safe electric trimmer which
you can use pretty much anywhere on your
body to get rid of unwanted hairs great
tool
we also have the crop reviver and the
crop preserver the crop reviver is a
ball spray toner and the crop preserver
is an anti-shaping bull deodorant great
tools for making it smell heavenly down
there
on top of that
we also have jockeys
and
a disposable
magic mat to get rid of hairs and a
travel bag as well and on top of that we
also have the weed whacker which you can
use to get rid of unwanted hairs in your
nostrils and your ears for this
exclusive offer just go to manscape.com
and use the code kiwitalks for 20 off
plus free shipping
how difficult was the momentum physics
you know how you jump through and
then you come out yeah
that from a physics standpoint it
actually wasn't too bad because um
we basically they would just take
whatever vector you had going in they'd
transform it
through the portal and then you'd fly
out the other end and we like i said we
had a really robust um physics system
from hl2 so luckily a lot of that just
sort of worked
the harder part was kind of making that
um fit for everybody because like i said
we
the original portal had a lot of like
okay you're going to fly out of here and
shoot a portal and drop through a thing
and do this and there was actually a
really specific part in portal where you
would put a portal up high and you would
jump out and put down another portal and
then that would send you even further
yeah and we could see in the numbers
that that cut out literally like half
the audience like it seemed to be that
half the audience would stop around that
point because they just couldn't do it
and they're like well if it's only going
to get harder i don't want to do this so
that was a big reason we kind of said oh
okay we gotta if we want people to play
this thing that we're working so hard on
we should try to like not have that so
much
so that was a harder challenge of like
we want to give you that experience of
flying through the air but we don't want
to make that a skill cap thing where
you're like well i guess i'm just not
made for this game especially since we
really wanted portal to throw its arms
around the biggest audience possible in
a way that you know
hl2 or tf2 didn't do right like they
were more for gamers and we felt like
portal was our opportunity to bring
younger kids into the fold bring the
parents into the fold and especially
with co-op to do all those things
and actually co-op ended up being a
little bit where that stuff lived
because
it was fun to watch your buddy fly
through the air and die and you'd laugh
and come back whereas when you did it in
the single-player game you it wasn't as
funny so it was kind of like it was kind
of picking our battles
did gabe ever come through and watch the
development or chip in any ideas
yeah at that time leave you to do your
thing
yeah he was more hands-off during hl2
gabe was more involved in gabe i don't
if you haven't met him gabe is a very
imposing guy like he's literally just a
tall tall dude
and and also his mannerisms can be very
imposing and so when i'm like 20 and
he's like nhl2 like taking me out for
lunch giving me game ideas i'm like yes
mr newell like just like hands down
freaking out um and i think over time
gabe kind of realized like okay like i
should let the game teams do what i pay
them for and you know he would stop in
and give us feedback and you know i
think his things were
he was worried about um
when we redesigned so we redesigned
gladys for portal 2 because she was
going to have a bigger
role and we felt like the old model
wasn't quite going to give us what we
needed he was very adamant about giving
gladys a face and we were like i don't
think so like i think we really want to
go a different direction
and so we sort of like went back and
forth them a bit and then i think after
a while he's like all right you guys got
it like i'm just gonna leave you to it
and he would check in with me personally
to say like how you doing like are you
stressed like how's life going
um but i think at that point he was kind
of realizing that
he hadn't sort of i i think he always
wanted to be part of the team but being
gabe and being in his position that
never really worked i feel because
people would be like whatever you say
and i think he was more like no no i
want to like
be part of the team and come up with
ideas and that was really hard for
people so i think there was a period
where he kind of stepped back and was
like all right i guess i'm just not
going to be able to
to interact with everyone that way and
i'll just work at a higher level and and
that was all right
yeah i suppose that's that's
understandable given the presence that
he is
yeah and the positions he he's in it's
oh my god it would be like me yeah motor
or something
[Laughter]
yeah true true was there any particular
mechanic or something particular that
just took you ages to get right which is
something that was a nightmare to do
probably the hardest area was when you
it was probably the underground stuff
where you fall down and you're into the
old aperture area there's a section in
the beginning where you're sort of just
walking around doing exploration and
you're sort of like using portals in a
way that people would imagine doing that
in half-life 2 where you're like i'm
going to see this thing in the distance
and put a portal and walk through and do
all these things
that was actually really difficult
because um we wanted to make that
interesting and fantastical but
it was so
sort of out of
people's
i don't know out of their mind of like
how they were going to approach it that
they would get into an area that was
more like half-life two and they would
just approach it like half-life two so
they're just looking around and they're
just trying to find the door to open and
we're like no there's a big portal
surface up there remember you have a
portal gun they're like yeah i got this
i want to find a crowbar i don't know
what it was it was just like it put them
in a different space
so that one took a lot of work and even
in the end i think that one was kind of
one of the the weaker areas just in
terms of being able to sell it because
it just
it it didn't have we were always able to
rely on this really clear design
language of like white surfaces are this
and dark surfaces are like that and now
we sort of put you in this sort of
monotone-ish area and we had to like be
really heavy-handed with like there's a
big white thing up here and everything
else isn't um so that was really
difficult we went we cut a bunch we went
back and forth and you know we just kind
of turned on that
everything else
like i said it was kind of like we
really quickly seized on
what was working and what didn't and
then just iterated on it so it and
everything else felt like a pretty
healthy like you know we put time into
it we get stuff out of it um that was
pretty good um
so yeah i think i think it was probably
the underground that was the hardest nut
to crack for us over time
yeah fair enough fair enough where it
was a portal three ever considered or no
because paul
yeah
you're probably like i'm done
exactly yeah yeah
i'm done yeah because i think portal 2
is a complete package i don't even know
how you would
uh
improve on that it seems like yeah
everything is complete after that
yeah
because
it was hard for us when we were making
portal 2 because we're like okay how are
we going to
how are we gonna like continue portal
because portal sort of tried to put a
bow on it itself
and steam gave us this ability to kind
of retcon in this thing which is kind of
cool we were okay with it at the time
because nobody had done it so we're like
okay we're technically
you know kind of right counting this but
steam makes it so it's canon so whatever
but um
yeah i don't
i i'm sure they could do that stuff i
think with f-stop we had kind of
envisioned something that was more
aperture it was kind of like not just
portal but aperture as a whole and a lot
of the cave johnson stuff actually came
from that period where we were working
on this totally different thing and then
that sort of morphed into where it was
later so we didn't lose a lot of work
there we just kind of took on a new life
but yeah i don't know it
i never say never because actually
a big part of what made portal 2 work is
that
when we started portal 2 we were like in
this mindset if we're going to do this
different mechanic we're going to change
it up a bit people want new things they
don't want the same old thing and we
just we just beat our head against the
wall for six months and then it was
getting kind of dire and we were like i
don't think this is gonna work you know
we're saying we're making portal there's
no portal gun
and at that time the company went off to
do left for dead and so
almost everybody went to work on that to
help ship it and then myself garrett
ricky and john guthrie who's like a
super genius like hl2 designer like most
of the most awesome stuff in half-life
and hl2 john was a part of he's just
amazing
the three of us were kind of left behind
in it
scott lynch who who's the um
like what does he know i guess he's the
ceo i don't know he he was one of the
biz guys he's like the master biz guy he
came to us and said hey xbox wants you
to make portal for the um or sorry
microsoft wants you to make x uh portal
for the xbox can you do that and we're
like yeah we'll just port it and then we
had a thought we were like well actually
there's this cool mod that came out that
adds a bunch of mechanics maybe we can
put that in as well
um and clean it up and then that'll add
a little extra value it'll make the xbox
version special
and so we worked there it was like a
really young guy in israel i think and
he had made it so we we had licensed it
from it and we took it on board and we
kind of cleaned it up and made it our
own
and so it was just the three of us
for the most part working on that but it
was really crucial to portal 2's
development because it made us back up
and sort of resaturate ourselves as
developers in portal and take on these
new mechanics and go oh you know
actually i think there are more things
we can do here and i think we've been
too quick to dismiss
how much more we can do which seems more
obvious in retrospect but at the time it
felt like you know we we were kind of
new designers coming in
um
like i you know i was coming off ep 2
and i was kind of taking over portal so
i i was sort of not really as um
immersed in it so going through that
product even though it was relatively
simpler
it made us really back up and go hey
actually i think there's something here
and so when that finished and the team
came back
we started to transition people into
these new ideas and that's really when
portal 2 took off so i feel like if that
xbox port wouldn't have happened
portal 2 may not have happened right or
it may have happened in this really
different way that i wouldn't have been
involved in or you know could have come
years later so it's just always
interesting those weird little lucky
breaks that happen that make you like
pause and reflect um and that's always
been the case
at valvin everywhere i've worked there's
always this reflection point where
you're like our game is awful and then
you kind of back up and go how do we
make our game not awful and we were
lucky at valve that we could do that a
lot of game companies have that
inflection point and then their
publishers like great okay bye and they
take it and you know it they they kind
of know what's going out the door on
unfinished but we were lucky at valve we
could always have that inflection point
and then kind of sit down and go
okay let's rip this up let's take the
good parts let's let's piece it back
together and that always gave us the
ability to really make really great
products i think is that we could take
the time to refine what we had and to
really sit back and analyze it versus
just going uh we just got to get this
out the door that's our best shot like
that's the best we could do in the time
we had um and so yeah i was always felt
really fortunate that we could do that
there
was it always intentional to add stuff
from portal one like in terms of little
easter eggs i think
if i remember correctly there's like one
chamber in portal 2 chamber 19 maybe and
it's one of the rooms from portal that's
reversed i think where it's backwards
yeah so uh
some there's kind of two things there
one is yeah we definitely wanted to tie
the two in so there's lots of ratman
stuff and what happened with him
but i personally took a lot of
inspiration we had this problem in the
game which was
if you just played portal we didn't want
to make you learn portals all again but
at the same time if you've never played
portal we had to teach you so it's like
okay how do we do this in a way that's
good for both and i was really inspired
personally by super metroid i always
loved the way super metroid started out
where it's like you're coming down to
the planet and you're going through
you kind of going through it backwards
right you're like going through where
mother brain is and doing all that stuff
and you turn it on and everything comes
back to life and that was really where i
was like hey let's do this let's have
you so you're going back through the
chambers
but now they're all derelict and they're
beat up and they're not quite working
and they're they're you know
everything's broken
and so that gave us a way if you played
the original game you're like oh this is
cool yeah um i know how to do this i'll
breeze right through it but i'm getting
to see the the cool new setting and if
you'd never play portal then you're
getting trained as well along the way
and and for the most part we used all
the puzzles there were a couple that in
hindsight we were able to tweak so if
you go back they're not canonically
correct there are a few that we made
better because there was some randomness
that we took out
but by and large we we were able to kind
of do that so that was
that was a nice way to tie the two in
that did a bunch of heavy lifting on the
storytelling but also did a lot more
heavy lifting on you know how do we get
you up to speed with all like there's a
whole game before this we don't know if
you played it how can we as tersely as
possible kind of get you up to speed
yeah well you did a good job because i
actually played portal 2 before portal
one oh yeah
yeah then i went back and played four to
one but yeah so it was very easy for me
to get into it and understand the
mechanics so you did a good job
awesome there we go we worked it out
because um how much of the glados stuff
changed at all did glados change much or
because i i know
originally because when you first start
off portal 2 there's the announcer that
speaks
and i think there's a file where it used
to be glados or is you're going to use
glados and then it got replaced with the
announcer like an old yeah pre-recording
or something
yeah i
i don't remember a glad gladys having
those lines at some point
in in our
sorry i always give you way more back
but maybe that's what you want
there's always like yeah uh
so
at valve we would do this thing called
overwatch where basically we would make
what was effectively a demo and then
show it to our peers and they would
break down what was good or bad and that
was kind of the inflection point that we
had so they would say like this is
really good this stuff you're doing is
dumb don't do that and then the team
would go back and you know pick up and
try to build the real game after that so
in that period before that it's kind of
like you know we're building that
overwatch demo that was sort of more of
a hub structure and in that hub
structure gladys
was you were rebuilding her so you were
kind of going down these hubs to grab
cores and bring them back to her so
you're trying to rebuild her to the
point where she would basically help you
out it never really works story wise
because you're like why am i helping her
it was kind of weird yeah but um so
that's why we didn't keep that part it
was just an idea but but wheatley came
out of getting those cores and
interacting um but anyway so so after
that we kind of knew okay we want you to
put glados back together but it has to
be kind of antagonistic from the
beginning and at some point gladys
didn't know who you were
and it was like she was going to have
amnesia and then she was going to slowly
figure out who you were and it was going
to be a problem but that never worked
either because characters would like the
player would go to gladys and she's like
who are you and they're like well i know
who you are it doesn't make sense that
you don't know who i am even if she had
amnesia it didn't feel good so we just
we just cut that and she was like on you
right away
um
but yeah i don't i don't remember gladys
having those announcement parts in the
beginning i think that announcer
section was just those guys going hey
what would it be like to have to record
a bunch of lines of like an apocalypse
has occurred but we don't know which of
the apocalypses has occurred so like
they just got so much content out of
that that they just were like riffing
forever so it worked out pretty well as
a structure for them
what was it like doing the turn you know
where wheatley
becomes the antagonist
was it was there much refinement with
that or was that pretty set from the
get-go
it was
trying to think on that one i think from
the i think for a while we knew that was
going to happen because
we we wanted that section afterwards
trying to think there's so many
whiteboard meetings they'll blow into it
that's that's where blair's the
whiteboard made yeah yeah
yeah um
so that wasn't too bad i think the
harder part was kind of going well how
do we sell wheatley
um
kind of turning on you
and he doesn't really necessarily he
kind of is mad at gladys and you're just
sort of collateral damage that goes with
it
until later when he's kind of taken over
but i think once they had the idea of
him being this kind of like idea
suppression core where he's like the
dumb tumor um then that all started
rolling in it was like okay he's gotta
we gotta you know replace glados and
then all this stuff's gonna happen
um
so yeah i
i think the hardest part if i recall was
just figuring out like okay how are we
going to
make it plausible that he takes over and
becomes this villain in the span of like
five minutes and i think
as part of his stephen merchant was
great like he was just able to ad-lib
and sell so much of that character that
you just kind of went along with it
because it was hilarious and i think
also wheatley was dumb enough that you
were kind of like yeah it doesn't seem
like it would take much to corrupt him
like
that's embarrassing little hint of power
and he's going to be off on his own so
it ended up working out better but that
was one of those things where i think we
we kind of stressed over it and then
once we had recorded it and kind of saw
it in place we're like okay it kind of
works it's not as bad as we thought so
yeah sometimes you just don't know until
you get the real dialogue and kind of
put it all together
so given the weight of expectations that
you had on yourself being the project
lead was there any
point in time where you're just being
overwhelmed and you're like
how am i going to do oh absolutely
yeah no i was overwhelmed from day one
um it it was tough i mean from my own
personal standpoint i i've wanted to
make games since i first got a nintendo
back when i was eight right so all my
life that's what i wanted to do that's
what i wanted to do and i think getting
to the point of being a project lead
even though i mean a project we
developed doesn't mean you're like the
design king it just means you're mostly
managing people but even still it was
kind of like for me it was my chance to
go okay now i can actually
prove what i've thought which is that
i'm okay at making games but if i mess
this up then i'm not gonna get another
chance and maybe i've been wrong all
this time so there was that that yeah
that weight of expectation and i think
it was tough too i remember so garrett
ricky um he was a really young guy at
the time too
and he had just come off a portal so you
imagine like you go from digipen to this
big game company to suddenly having this
massive hit on your hands to then being
like
the co-lead of this big follow-up and
you're just like
so he and i would just we would always
just steal off in the middle of the day
and like go to some like we literally
would go to like some parking ramp and
just stand there and like talk about
what we're going to do and like okay
what if we did this way we did this what
we did this and so we he and i just sort
of like did a ton of work in the
beginning trying to figure out how to
even structure anything and how to move
forward because it was hard too because
valve
doesn't really have a process per se
like the process is sort of whatever you
make it
so i wasn't coming in going oh okay
these are all the tried and true methods
i used to make this work it was sort of
like this is a different project than
we've ever done with a different team
than we've ever done with different
people so how are you going to make it
work make it work you know and i'm like
you know however old i was at time like
26 i'm like great thanks so a lot of it
was just trying to do it on the fly and
you know
trying to find like management software
that was all useless and yeah in the end
it was just all
google documents but but it is hard i
mean i think um
you know i was i had
i guess i'd been married for a couple
years at that point and
game making is really stressful and as
i'm sure you've talked to a ton of
people like anytime you have any
creative endeavor and you have a
deadline you're just gonna have this
nasty crunch right like
i don't know how to get around it
not i mean there's ways to get around it
if a manager is giving you a dumb
deadline that's stupid right they should
make realistic deadlines but part of the
problem we always had is that we were
kind of making this problem for
ourselves because we loved what we were
doing so we just kept adding stuff and
then it's like no no no like we actually
have to finish this oh but i want to add
some stuff you know and so we were
always kind of making our own lives
miserable because we were you know we
just kept adding things in and that's
that's part of the passion that makes
the project good so it's like
if you'd strip that away the game
wouldn't be half of what it is but at
the same time it did cost a lot of us a
lot of our lives right it was just i
mean i think all the grey in my beard
comes from portal 2.
um so it was tough i mean my wife was
getting really tired of the project and
and it was kind of weird like a mistress
because i was working all these hours
and i think i was just so
caught up in this it was like it's all i
thought about was
what are we going to run into the next
day like what do i need to do the next
day where are we going to go from design
so it was just this constant
uh
stress of
are we going to mess this up are we
going to make something people hate are
they going to be like man i love porta
but portal 2 is so awful like why did
they do that valve has finally made a
terrible game and like all these things
just running around your head like i'm
gonna be the guy who like ruins
everything for everybody all this stuff
we've worked for um and it was tough i
mean in the last
i think in the last three weeks my wife
literally was like look we're gonna
divorce if you don't stop and i was like
okay so i called the next day and was
like i can't come into the office like i
uh
uh someone else who had been doing a
really great job on the project cuda i
just called him he's like all right you
gotta go talk to playstation about um us
on the ps3 and i can't come into the
office for a couple weeks and it wasn't
the worst thing in the world because
basically at that point we had kind of
we had wrapped up stuff enough that it
was okay
but it was a really weird experience
because i went from like
200 on to just going i gotta be away
from this i gotta i gotta step back
and it was tough after that because my
wife was just like look you can't do
that again
you know it's just fair enough yeah yeah
yeah and and now and and i know eric
wolpa like he had just had a kid at the
time and he told his wife like look
you're just gonna have to deal because i
am just so up against it you know with
with writing and everything and i didn't
have a kid at the time so i don't think
i even appreciated how hard that would
have been um and now i do have a kid
it's like i don't know how i would fall
into that structure anymore like how
would i make that work um so it does
feel like
it's a hard one to figure out i do feel
like video games in a lot of ways are
kind of a younger person's game just in
terms of like the amount you have to
give into it um
to a degree um but it was hard for me
because as a manager i didn't i didn't
want to be the person who was like doing
nine to five and then expecting people
to do a lot of work i was always gonna
try to be there longer than everybody
else and work harder than everybody else
and that's just is not a recipe for a
good life
because how do you manage creatives
anyway because creatives
you know that
in my experience they can be a bit more
fragile as well yeah because it's their
work and they're putting so much
maintenance art
so
you can't just be like no this is not
good they might go after yeah you know
so
it was it was hard apparently i was good
at that um sometimes they don't know how
but i think luckily i i was really
lucky in that
the people at valve were pretty
incredible so there really wasn't
anybody that i was like oh man this
person like oh man they just they just
turned in bad art again it was pretty
much everything was always going to be
awesome and i think that we we spent a
lot of time trying to find people
to work on things they were going to be
passionate about because i felt pretty
strongly that if people were passionate
about things
even if they jumped in the deep end they
were going to make it work and 99
of the time that was true
there were a couple times where there
were problems and we had to tweak stuff
but for the most part i had tried really
hard to get the team in on all the
decisions i didn't want to be in a
position of saying this doesn't work for
the game and i'm not going to tell you
why it was always like
here's what i think the game is here's
where i think we're going
and if we all agree then let's look at
this thing through that filter and see
how we can change it or how it does or
doesn't fit and so i feel like a lot of
people told me a lot of times that they
would come to me with ideas or they
would come to me with art
and they would go away understanding the
project better not just knowing what
they needed to tweak and that was
important to me because i felt like i
really wanted everybody to be making
those decisions about the game and to be
thinking about the game at a high level
and what the product was and what people
were going to experience
and not just sort of burrow down into
well i'm just going to make this thing
and it's really interesting to me and
good luck where it is like i wanted
everyone to understand sort of the
context of where their work lived and i
think that just made everybody feel
more invested and like i said we got
more ideas because people were able to
think they they felt the freedom to
think at that higher level it wasn't
just that's great buddy i just needed to
go and make this model it was like well
why do you want to make this like let's
talk about it and there was a cost to
that i mean i spent a lot of time
talking to people and trying to
communicate that but i think the value
was that
um we just had a really tight-knit team
and people came away from that product
being really proud of it and they i
think a lot of that was they felt really
um
a lot of ownership and investment in it
because they weren't excluded from those
things they were they felt like they
were on the ground floor they were part
of that team building it they weren't
just a contractor that was on the
outskirts that you know was kind of
looking in from from where they were
outside
so does your brain always operate like
this like it's always going going going
or did you get to points where you your
eyes would literally glaze over and your
brain was fried and you're like i have
no idea
what to even do right now i don't
remember so maybe it's the latter
no i felt like um
i have this kind of perverse thing where
i feel like i operate well under stress
but then
you're under stress so it's kind of
terrible so i don't know it's like i
don't know how to work when i'm not
under stress and luckily through the
whole project i was under stress so i
felt like i was i was pretty on all the
time just because i had this like this
uh this noise floor of stress but um
yeah no i
it was hard to turn off i think that was
a big thing because you would just spend
all day thinking about this stuff and
you know talking about all these things
and then you come home and you're still
like
and i think that was that was hard on
you know my wife because she'd be like
hey how was your day and i'm like
like telling her all this valve stuff
and then i'd kind of just like
crash and she's like well okay great
talk you know like i'm tired of hearing
about this
um
so i think that was hard i think
it would have been better to find a way
to switch off but but it is difficult
and
yeah and and i have this question too
because so since i'm retired
i have this question of like
can i make something really interesting
if i'm not in that mode
and i don't know like i think that
remains to be seen because i think even
though it was kind of unhealthy and
weird
you were just like
just saturated in these ideas all day
long and so everything was being put
through the filter portal too it was
like i'd see something on a shelf and be
like oh that reminds me of this thing
here and we can use this we can do this
it's like you were just kind of
vacuuming in the world all the time into
this this kind of creative thing that
you're doing
and
i just feel like it would be hard to
compete with that if i was like going
home and not doing that but at the same
time that's not
sustainable so
it was kind of like i felt like that
worked for one thing and now you know i
have to find a different way and that
may just be a personal process thing of
how i work that needs to tweak i'm not
sure i think it's something that's
echoed quite a bit with game developers
i mean i've spoken to a number of them
and it just seems like one of those
things and
it probably is similar in the music
industry in the film industry where you
just can't shut off and you're just
always thinking of the next thing
yeah yeah so i i totally feel you and
then you add crunch on top of that which
which place apart i imagine the crunch
wasn't too bad though
it wasn't too bad um
we
you know we i think
we decoupled ourselves from the holiday
season up until that point it was always
like holiday season is coming we have to
put the game out so you get these nasty
crunches up against that and i think
around that time we kind of stepped back
and we're like is this even a thing and
we sort of looked at the numbers and
we're like i don't think this is the
thing i think we've been thinking this
is a thing but we're in a new world now
where people buy things on steam
like why don't we just release this in a
window where nobody is and we'll just do
that and so that that allowed us to kind
of go oh okay let's just relax that a
bit and i think we had like a press
release where we were talking we had
like slipped by
like three weeks or something due to
like i think we were going through
certification on playstation and so the
writers just wrote up this funny little
like you know the world's smallest uh
slip as or this you know the slightest
delay has happened and we did it that
way so that that did take a lot of
pressure off
um
but it still was
i think because we were
why did we put it out and it was like
xbox plus playstation plus
pc plus mac yeah i think even mac so we
just had like that was the bigger thing
from a tech standpoint is our surface
area for testing was so massive
it was just so difficult and if if you
haven't been through certification on pc
we would test and do a really good job
but ultimately we're like oh just patch
it's not a big deal but at that time it
was like certification on those two
platforms were super rigid
and they were they were different and so
we kind of had what we knew xbox was in
our head but we didn't know what
playstations was
and so you'd bump up against these
things where they're like uh no you're
not going to pass because in the loading
screen this little bar doesn't spin fast
enough and you're like oh my god like
why does this matter is that well i i
yeah well i think what they were saying
is like it's not interacting with him
enough so a lot of times when you see
games load and you'll see like hints pop
up
a lot of times that's trying to um
satisfy that requirement so it's
interactive or like interesting when
it's loading because people are like
well i don't know what to do like we're
loading the game just give us a break
but um yeah so there's a lot of stuff
like that where the game was kind of
done the recording was done and then it
was just a lot of like freaking out
about um all those things and it's tough
too because for steam we don't care like
i can i can fix a bug the day before and
then it just goes out right yeah we
don't have to make discs but for the
other platforms you have to go into
their certification at a certain time
you have to pop out at a different time
successful and then you have this window
of manufacturing so you suddenly have
this like really crappy thing where
you're like well if i don't hit this a
week ahead of time and go into cert at
the right time now we've been pushed
back a month now production gets pushed
back a month now all the advertising we
did
is useless or less useful so we just you
know wasted millions of dollars so a lot
of the stress came from that more than
just finishing the game
and i think that's why probably after
that that was less interested
in that that venture yeah well how much
time does
certification just on one additional
platform how much time does it does that
actually add to development
uh i it would have added
probably a month just in terms of
specific work that we had to go off and
do just to make it work for those things
you know because it would be like oh we
dip under 60 frames well i was probably
30 frames per second in this one area
that's unacceptable because they would
be like oh if you get under 30 frames
per second for three seconds or whatever
it is in certain areas we'll red flag
you and you'll get kicked out so you're
like oh my god so it was like okay like
what are we gonna do just for this one
area just for the ps3 and then we had
co-op on top of it which made it harder
because portals were already hard
because you could have a big scene and
then you're rendering that scene again
through the portal
um and then when you had co-op you could
do that multiple times right because you
could see through that portal which you
could see through that portal you know
and so we had to do all this work around
like okay we can't let you see through
too many portals and do all that stuff
and so and it was all really boring
stuff right it wasn't stuff that was
really making the quality of life that
much better it was just that those
platforms
holders were like
and fair enough they're like we have to
make some
standard and you're gonna have to adhere
to it yeah but it was super stressful
too because you go into certification
and you just sit there
and it's just like you're waiting for
that ding to come into your inbox going
you failed so everyone just stops
because you can't do any work you can't
submit anything else so everyone's just
like kind of freaking out waiting for
this email to come in saying oh you
failed now you know quick and then you
have to jump back on and try to you know
fix it as fast as you could and
sometimes you're like i don't even know
what we failed on so that i i don't miss
that that part was terrible has that
gotten easier though with time
like are the certifications like are
they less
strict
i'm guessing not just because there's
still discs being produced but i know
for valve we were like like we can put
out a patch and and i think most pc
developments like that it's like you do
your best job you don't want a bad
release but if there's some
tiny little thing that a small
percentage of people are gonna hit then
yeah patch that later um don't kill
yourself over that but i wouldn't be
surprised if cert is the same as it's
always been
well because there are a lot of games
these days that get released in a broken
state you know so i'm wondering if the
certification has gotten less strict
i i bet that's political i think a lot
of times because there was that that
aspect too where it's like if you were a
big enough game they'd be like
it's okay for you but maybe not for
other people so you know so i'm sure
like the call of duty's and whatnot have
you know they're they're obviously
you know kind of probably strong arming
those platform holders a bit but i don't
know we we didn't have that much sway so
we just kind of did what we were told
fair enough fair enough now before i let
you go uh obviously i i do want to talk
to you we did talk a little bit off here
about zero fan page and just what you're
working on i know you probably can't go
into specifics but just a rough idea of
what it is
yeah so um
what i started working on was i i built
a nintendo emulator and then i realized
that that was the same chipset of an
apple ii which is the old computer i
grew up with so i was like oh i wonder
if i can make an apple 2 emulator and i
did and then i was like i want to put
this inside unreal engine and make it
work in real time so i actually got the
game an apple ii working perfectly in
real time in unreal engine and then my
puzzle brain was going oh yeah i can
totally make a puzzle game out of this
so then that sort of turned into going
okay i want to let you use this tool and
you know the basic programming language
and all the things that come with this
kind of old school 80s
thing
put you on a dying spaceship and make
you try to survive um and so that's what
i'm working on right now is this kind of
idea of like um it's probably more
akin to
mist or ribbon in a lot of ways and then
it's a lot of like environmental like
tinkering stuff and figuring out things
by by viewing them and sort of um it's
not as structured as portal in any way
um but all the lessons i took from
portal carry over to it so hopefully
it'll be it'll be exciting for everybody
but yeah you can check that out on steam
it's called xero page um and then um you
can follow me on on twitter and you'll
you'll find it there but uh yeah it's
just it's been a nice thing in
retirement it's really just me in my
office just kind of riffing on with all
my experience and what i find
interesting so it's sort of
um
it's it's a little sad i miss my big
team not just because they're super
talented but it's nice creatively to
like sit in a room with people and throw
ideas around so i've been trying to like
um reach out to my old co-workers and
try to pick their brains a bit and kind
of get them to to help me out with uh
different ideas but uh yeah it's cool
hopefully hopefully in the next couple
years um it'll be coming out
yeah yeah
well yeah that's right that's just
that's the big question mark right
yeah yeah yeah but at least you don't
have to be stressed and under pressure
and that's the wife hounding you all the
time so that's right yeah now i can fit
it in i'm just at home doing that and
make it work for myself so yeah
hopefully i'll find a healthier better
way and that'll yeah
cool well hey josh this has been a
pleasure thank you so much for uh doing
this so if anyone wants to keep up to
date with um this game and
you in general what's the best place for
them to do that
yeah you can just go to um
xerohyphenpage.com or xero.page
and you'll find the website there or you
can follow me at
xeropage underscore game on twitter
and there's lots of stuff up there
there's some blog entries about what i'm
doing and you can see some videos and
presentations i've done about the
technology and if you grew up with an
apple ii it'll be super familiar and
exciting
cool
i just want to say portal 2
it's a timeless game it'll live on
forever
i if i had to rank my top 10 games of
all time portal 2 would definitely be in
there it's awesome it's a brilliant it's
a brilliant timeless game
i hope not yeah i was i felt super
privileged to be able to work on that
game and yeah it was a good one to go
out on yeah yeah awesome awesome awesome
cool all right well that's the show
everyone make sure you share like and
subscribe and uh until next time stay
safe
[Music]
you